[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we have a very very very
special episode it's an episode that we
thought you would never hear or more
specifically see right
it is the lost episode of ear biscuits
it actually was intended to be the first
episode of season 3 of ear biscuits but
we had some technical difficulties
because we're doing this video thing for
the first time and well we had this shot
and we also had this shot and that's
when you're supposed to say and we also
had this shot but some things happen
with the cameras so we lost we actually
never had this ship we never had link
shot and a little bit of the she points
did you have this shot it's important
for us to set things off on the right
try exactly beginning we didn't want a
compromised episode to be the first
episode of the video version of ear
biscuit ear biscuits is back you got to
make a big deal of it so we shelved it
it was a good conversation yeah it was
the very first one there was there was a
certain energy to the unknown of feeling
our way through bringing the roundtable
into the video format we took I mean we
we ended up baring our souls or other
body parts yeah not I mean not
physically it gets very personal but but
it gets very personal and then you know
from there we talked about you know I
talked about some personal stuff that is
happening in in my family's life that
ultimately having made the decision for
us to talk about it it was we wanted you
to be able to hear it and experience it
and share it with us so and we wanted to
put this little intro on the beginning I
mean obviously there were no technical
difficulties on the audio side but we
wanted to put this on both the video and
the audio version because we repeatedly
refer to this episode being the first
episode of your biscuits and you would
be very very confused if we didn't
just put this little intro on orienting
you to what's about to happen so you'll
just see the wide shot with one minor
exception but other than that it should
feel like a normal ear biscuit
experience don't be alarmed just accept
it
with no open your ears close-up shots of
us if that's your thing this isn't gonna
be the one you want to watch well you
can maybe do your own zooms and crops oh
okay thank you feel free to do your own
zooms and crop I don't think it's worth
it just just listen and enjoy this lost
episode of your biscuits it's found here
it is you already know how often we
touch our hair I mean on good mythical
morning but now it's gonna I'm just
really resisting the urge to touch my
hair currently yeah well I'm oh I want
to touch it all the time yeah you
constantly want to touch it the hair
yeah okay here so a lot has happened
since the end of season two of ear
biscuits and in one of those things that
has happened is a lot of people have
asked when does your biscuits coming
back and we've been like not anytime
soon that was sort of the standard line
yeah so we've been doing a lot of other
things of course good mythical morning
going strong as always I've been working
on our book we did buddy system this
year last year and but we still there
wasn't a figure out what it is that made
us want to do it I think it's we still
find ourselves having conversations yeah
between the two of us that no one else
hears and I think in the back of our
minds we're we are just thinking why am
I just talking to this guy yeah I mean
we should we should probably monetize
this that is the thinking all right well
no we should probably should share that
yeah yeah that's it that's probably
share that's a probably more palatable
way to play and we save stuff to talk
about on good mythical more but there's
still we we still end up talking we
spend so much time together and every
time we just talk to each other
it's
is it pointless no I you it seems like
you're questioning the foundations of
our friendship no I mean are you saying
that our friendship has become seems
like you're baiting me so outwardly
focused that it is no longer free we're
it's no longer for us and now it's just
for the mythical beasts well I don't
think that's the case then why do you
want to do this to monetize it No so it
well you know I'm sick I'm a sit on my
foot you do whatever you want you don't
have to justify a number of actions what
are halfway are you're gonna have to get
to a place where you can just do the
physical things without openly
acknowledging that like you thinking
about your hair I mean it I'm helping
you you help me
no but the I think the reason we want to
do this is because podcasting I mean
really when you talk about the things
that we've done that are the you know
the favorite of the things that we have
done we we enjoy a lot of different
things for a lot of different reasons
but the times that we've had at this
roundtable of done lighting it's a
totally different thing it's different
than gmm I mean we're not gonna put any
weird stuff on our head or eat something
that makes us vomit play a weird game
that's not what this is about and of
course it's not some something that's
been planned for for months on end is
meticulously presented in the way that
we want it to be presented like buddy
system okay yeah so this is our book but
this scratch is an itch of this is just
a totally different thing well it's
totally unplanned I think we've
demonstrated we don't have a clue what
we know we haven't even talked about
what today's show was going to be about
we yeah we've just and so there are it
is becoming that right now so far it's
just been us talking about doing it
let's just keep talking about it how
long can we stretch this to meta we
don't need to stretch anything out you
may appreciate this conversation if you
already are a fan of ear biscuits but
you know over six minutes in at this
point if this is your first year biscuit
you're like is this what is ear biscuits
just a podcast
Podcast no it's not we're just kind of
getting back in the swing of things
oh you know we get groove man I might
take my jacket off take your jacket off
I don't want it cuz it's such a plain
t-shirt it's taking shoulder off but
then put it back that's what I did I
mean I've gone through so many
iterations already told her I got a
v-neck I recently heard okay III wear a
lot of Enochs and I'll just be honest
with you and I wear a lot of plain
v-necks you know links kind of the funky
t-shirt guy and I'm the plain t-shirt
guy I might wear some patterns of you
know colors that shouldn't go together
on like a collared shirt that's kind of
what I do
oh yeah but I'm not really a graphic tee
kind of guy you've kind of you've sort
of got that on lockdown but I have a lot
like you can't purchase a tee me no I
mean I just I I don't like it when my
t-shirt says too many things to too much
I don't want I lied to keep people
guessing like a ninja okay so but I wear
a v-neck and I wore one to a party
recently and a friend of mine who is
sort of equally a friend of my wife's as
well we were was talking to he's very
fashionable person you also know this
person but I'm not gonna disclose his
name right now can I guess no you can't
guess we're not gonna play a game we
don't play games we don't play go play
games was I at the party no you were not
at this one okay you weren't you weren't
invited I didn't tell you actually
that's your and you left early I was
there earlier yeah and he began to tell
talk to my white as this part about my
shirt let's call him Sanchez and he what
Sanchez was like you know v-necks he's
very he's very direct he has good
relationship with my wife he's like you
know he really shouldn't you know
v-necks are like five years ago it's out
five years five years ago like a half -
yeah how did I miss a half decade well
hacks are not working well look at well
casing how long have you had that v-neck
five months really well I I've
constantly read I mean first of all I
want a v-neck because I knew they were
going out no the reason that you don't
wear a v-neck don't because I you
already you've told me this I'm not
making anything up the
you haven't told me you told me you
don't wear v-necks because of the patch
of hair that pop too much layer too much
here and I don't I don't have a whole
lot you know I gotta go a little bit
lower than a deep V to get there but I
just can't believe that's something that
is as subtle as the shape of the collar
is something that can go out of style so
I refute Sanchez I don't believe that V
necks are out of style I don't think
that they can they actually can go out
of style
I'm gonna keep wearing them unless you
know the people in the comments on one
of the platforms wear ear biscuits is
enjoyed prove me wrong I am yeah so
you're inviting you read is inviting you
to let him know if V necks are out and
don't just take his side because you
like him be honest I think this is a
moment an opportunity where you can help
the guy I mean Sanchez was took a risk
and ret threw it in his face I don't
need a hater
on a podcast that he's not listening to
you I don't need a sling shave him at
the time I need a well get defense I had
walked out of the room he know he said
it to hurt you weren't even named it was
one of those things like when you got to
break up with a girl and you tell her
friend ooh
yeah yeah you got to tell a man he's
meeting his v-necks out of style you
tell his wife oh gosh you go through the
wife and how fashionable is Sanchez cuz
I still don't know you're talking about
he's he's pretty fashionable
I mean I've taken some cues from him
done really yeah because he wear like
the big round collars no no no he's not
super neck super naggy doesn't wear
super necks I just made that up
he's fashionable though I respect his
fashion choices but but you know what
you're getting old brother that's what
it is man well that is something that I
always you wear it proudly you're you
you're old and I'm right behind you okay
I think that's what you've missed
I mean if that's what this podcast is
about like we have aged but there's only
certain things we can talk to you about
and one of those is just that we're
getting we're getting you know well let
me let's be more specific about that of
course we're getting older
everyone is getting older right now
what's up anyone who's beating the aging
process I'm glad you said that
Baez that may
me feel better and we're not getting any
older faster than anyone elses
technically however I do feel and I
don't know how long it's been it's been
over a year since the end of season two
of ear biscuits well over a year yeah
and I feel like in my life and in my
body more than a year has passed that's
how I feel
and I think about life stage when I
think about like because we're working
too hard no I'm just saying when I think
about the things that have happened when
I think about the fact that both of us
independently have scheduled trips to
see a proctologist within a week of one
another
that's yes that's a sign that something
has changed in the anus particularly yes
specifically like I get when you get old
you get hemorrhoids young people can get
hemorrhoids also now you're gonna tell
them what we went yeah for hemorrhoids I
mean I've had I've had the condition I'm
not gonna say that H word anymore
I'm just gonna say the condition so
we're a mean it's official we're talking
about hemorrhoids now but the condition
you want to talk about them in general
or specifically as it relates to us I'll
talk about the experience I'll talk
about going to a proctologist okay do
that is it by the way they're called
Allison they're called colorectal
surgeons now which is scary right for
the beginning right it's like I'm when I
was in yes sir when I was in the wait a
moment
I'm abajo in and I saw the certificate
of the doctor and it said colorectal
surgeon I was like whoa I didn't sign up
for that I don't need a rectal surgery
that's not what I'm here for I just got
a little discomfort well the guy that I
went to cuz I went to a different guy
cuz I you know I just didn't I didn't
want to I just didn't I didn't I felt
like that would be too intimate between
the two of us if I went to the same guy
that
if he did that to you and he did it to
me yeah what if we showed up at the same
time what if he put us in the same room
it's like we're friend it's like it's
like going on a date with the same girl
within a week of each other it's a
sloppy second situation it's like it's
like separates in Reverse because he's
sticking his finger in our bus gosh I
well it's like I'm just being honest
that's what happens when you go to a
proctologist that's what happens is that
is what happened and 'red fair well I
went in we're talking about this though
I just let it register okay here it it
don't I'm not gonna let it register that
way out yes you're talking about it well
this goes back man I mean I don't
this is not like within the last year I
my aging is accelerating in like the
anal region exactly well let me explain
cuz it's not the condition that has has
is a sign of aging it's the willingness
to see someone about it that is a that
is a result of aging because chem roids
are very common like I do a lot of
Google searches for medical conditions a
little bit of a hypochondriac I haven't
really disclosed that before but I have
now and so if I see something with
hypochondria well I think that's someone
who doesn't worry that's me I don't know
is it a hypochondriac or hypochondria
because we got to be right about we got
it because I am that link your right is
hypochondriac a person who is abnormally
anxious about their health yes as
opposed to a hypochondriac someone who
is searched that really fast let's see a
concern about their health hypochondriac
is a common miss Burnam mispronunciation
someone mispronunciation someone who
when they believe they have something
they search it really fast oh oh a
hypochondriac is one of the things there
is nothing wrong with them despite
medical evidence that they got symptoms
of a disease are you kidding me that's
what I am so I was exactly wrong they're
both words no maybe that's the urban is
that the urban dictionary but
hypochondriac dot-org this is this is
fake news
but let your back but her but but let me
finish the point I'm a hypochondriac
just like my mom
just like my brother my dad does not
have this gene he's on my per country we
worry about urban ourselves and when we
see things and when I you can google a
condition and because so many people
Google conditions Google has figured out
that it would be most beneficial and
efficient if they put up the nature of
which the nature of the problem and how
common it is so you don't have to go
into WebMD or the like in order to just
make yourself silly so when you look up
hemorrhoids which incidentally say the
condition impossible to spell without
spell correction without you know you
know there's no M's in you think I can
spell it now because every is being
corrected so many times but no person I
believe this strongly no person has ever
just correctly spelled the condition and
of course I'm talking about hemorrhoids
when I say the condition for the last
time when just just on a whim just tried
to spell it but it's very common so it's
not I think like up to like 30 to 40
percent of the population will report
having the condition in their lifetime
so like that people report it how many
people don't report it seventy to eighty
so then a hundred percent of people have
look we've all got hemorrhoids from time
to time with condition well right the
condition I remember when mine popped up
or literally popped out I mean well come
on you don't we were at that we were in
New York City at the gel conference and
you know I don't live in New York and
when I visit there's this expectation
and the whole city set up so do you walk
around everywhere and we were we're
supposed to write and perform a song at
the same time on stage at a conference
called the gel conference Irene I was
really I was anxious about that and I
think and I you know must think turgut's
know can I get anxious I just like can
you use code words my condition place
yes there we go it's tight
that's where I hope some people hold the
stress in their shoulder let me just but
in US and saying say that again this is
the first one this is no this is so this
is Season three Episode one we've
decided to film it and we're talking
about the condition
III just thinking are they gonna show
the condition spot I want no no no it's
they're not you don't you don't ya you
you just not gonna mean that's just
chill because so chill right this isn't
what the podcast is going to be ear
biscuits is not going to be us so I'm
gonna be talking about this art the
condition or our conditions again but we
have to get it out of our system we
don't know what it's gonna be about and
somehow this early it has become about
us talking about our condition but what
I'm saying is I apologize and you can
stop listening now is I'm sorry
or watching it's gonna keep happening
around the NYC New York my WI fee II
yeah and wife you and your wife yeah
it's me and my wife and it's at one
point I just remembered feeling oh gosh
it's like it's just like it's like no it
didn't feel right man and it scared that
monkey out of me okay monkey I've had to
make up a word
I mean upon further inspection a little
bit later I was like oh that I mean it's
like I didn't immediately know it was
the condition I thought it was like I
didn't know what thot you were dying but
it was very scary most people think
they're dying I asked my wife to look at
how gosh that's intimacy yeah I mean he
scared her and then I mean I didn't do
anything about it and it kind of went
away for the most part but I've lived
with it for eight years yeah and you've
complained about it quite a bit but at a
certain point you get of a certain age
and you you reach a certain level of
discomfort and a couple of other
symptoms start to start to make an
appearance
and you like man I got to get in there
I no longer care if this means I have to
let someone who I who I meet within
seconds put their finger in my rectum
tell us about the proctologist you went
before me so why don't you I think I
think I may have told this story at some
point well maybe I didn't yeah I went
five years ago for the first time that's
right five years ago when I was having
my own issues with the condition while
we were traveling traveling around maybe
he's talking about two weeks ago
commercial Kings you went two weeks ago
I went five years ago that was the first
time the guy said that's my finger
what tell me that has he proper yeah
tell me the proper story well I mean it
was very sad the only thing I remember
is the thing I'm trying to forget you
know what I'm saying that's the
situation that tell me I mean not that
I'm into it but I just remember he says
want to know if my experience was the
same well from the first time from the
first time well the first time he said
he came in there and he was like I'd
like you to I'm gonna have you drop your
drawers you can leave your shirt on
he said drawers which makes well I know
I may I'm paraphrasing it five years ago
he said take your pants off leave your
shirt on which made me feel like a
cartoon character and because it
personally if I'm taking my pants off I
feel like I should take my shirt off -
there's no you feel so much more
vulnerable when you're just bottom half
naked then when you're just completely
naked completely naked is like warrior
but bottom half naked is I should be
violated you know what I'm saying it's
and I think they do that I think he
tells you you keep your top on because
you're trying to humiliate you humiliate
yeah yeah exactly
you're like Snoopy or Mickey man you're
right yogi yogi yogi wore a tie actually
I had on a shirt not just a tie take off
everything but put on this time but then
he says and me and Marissa hey I don't I
don't remember her name
me and Marissa we'll be in in a second
I'm like well who's Marissa you know and
all of a sudden there's a there's the
doctor who's a man her name and Marissa
no I'm making it up okay and
paraphrasing who's a woman and not just
a woman like a
like a like straight out of school like
too young for my comfort level and and
and it's not about your comfort level
about that's all I was thinking about
and he's like okay bend over and and
then he and then the next thing he said
was that's my finger and of course what
he meant by that is that's my finger
inside of you right now already
and that was my fingers it could be it
could be anything
is confirming that it was the finger and
he investigated did the doctor thing
that he needed to do and I put my pants
back on and he was like well yeah you've
got you've got the condition but it's
not too serious and here's some
something and going about your business
and I've had a good good five-year
stretch but it's probably a bad way I've
had a good five years good five years
where things have been okay and but then
recently when you started talking about
how you needed to see a doctor again I
was like you know that gave you the itch
to tell you the truth my condition is
never resolved itself and I think I need
to go back again getting closer to 40
should probably go and this time it was
basically the same exact situation but
the the doctor was much more personable
wasn't Marissa - Marissa say anything
you left that out
she made it gave me no compliments if
that's what you're asking she said
nothing I say they I I think they say it
time around no Marissa I think no nose
no Marissa for stage one this time
around and first of all I don't know how
your doctor had you do it but my doctor
had me get on my side like a baby
fetal the fetal position and that was
his that was his angle of approach
whereas the first guy it was bending
over a table oh wow so I definitely
preferred the it's more comfortable to
be in the fetal position because you
already feel like a baby you know the
you it's like having your temperature
taken so yeah when you bend over it's
like you're being punished yeah and so I
was more comfortable we had quite a
conversation while I was in this
position and then Marissa came in again
another lady I will just always call
anyone who's assisting a colorectal
colorectal surgeon
Arisa and it was another woman yeah and
that was when he went he did it like
this you know he did it he did a uh he
put a camera in there and I'm not
talking like a DSLR just a camera that
loves that's a diella DSLR going in
there I got to get my Instagram updated
every updated his Instagram but Marissa
update an Instagram know keep it
up-to-date you where'd your V lecture
talking about I don't know I don't even
use Instagram but I know the verb is not
okay toast okay
I don't know Instagram oh he just
updated his Instagram is that it what I
was trying to do is make a joke about
how you know that's what the doctor does
he takes a picture you butthole for his
Instagram but actually it was a it was a
camera that's just designed for the butt
and do you have it can I see it no it's
not disposable and you don't get to keep
it they take it out and he he said do
you have the picture he said come back
in three weeks which that's another week
for me oh nice
which incidentally which will make
another podcast he's monitoring
something in case you're wondering I'm
gonna be okay is he monitoring right now
is there a camera constantly removed now
but you you also have a comeback in
three weeks situation from what I heard
what you told me but you didn't give me
the details because you said you would
give me the details here on the show
well the doctor the nurse asked me
question we're halfway through this by
the way we're still talking about it but
you know well it's important yeah to get
it out and she was asking me all this
history questions while I'm fully
clothed Marissa yeah
Marissa she's everywhere she then if
she's leaving the room she's like take
off your pants and your underwear and
put on this gown you got a gown I got a
gown I didn't get it but I did leave my
shirt on and I put my gown over that but
it was open in the back and I sat back
down and then then he comes in and he
talks to me a little bit and you said
like the whole time he's talking to me
I'm like looking at his hand
yeah I'm like cause you have tiny ants
no and I you know I think you could tell
I was looking at his hand cuz he kept
moving it up by his face too like oh my
god
follow the hand mr. Neil visual joke
yeah right you do that
yeah yeah if your node V over there
listening to the audio version of your
biscuit just missed a visual when a link
said move the hand I took my hand and
put it into this the Spock symbol and
put it over my right eye it's very funny
in the in the in the video version it
worked not to make you feel that out I
think most people could enjoy both do
not enjoy the video version of your
biscuits while driving down the lanes
unless you're in the backseat watching
on a screen so I didn't hear anything he
said I was just waiting for him to say
bend over or roll over or whatever and
he looked like a dog and he said he said
I want you to I want you to lay on your
right side right side huh the first
thing he said was on my left side it's
like he was he was talking and I was
like I was answering to specific very
specific questions about the condition
and the sensations and the history of it
and he's like well let's take a look and
that's one of my you know you gotta keep
breathing that's the key how to keep
breathing yeah he's like lay on your
right side so I got in the fetal
position
yeah and I'm facing the wall much better
than the bent-over position I think that
it I mean I just can't imagine having to
do you've done it both ways yeah I agree
with your preference yeah and he did not
give me any warning he was just poked
right in there did it make that noise I
think I could help I could diagnose that
you have a problem
he's not supposed to make a cartoon
noise to pop a bubble oh gosh no he
didn't and it was it didn't feel great
and then it was like I'm gonna go four
quadrants and I want you to tell me how
that feels so it's like who knew it had
four quadrants it's like he's had is it
a good thing that I got four quadrants I
think everything has four quadrants well
he divided it into four but it
Circle and then that's the definition of
a quadrants just dividing something into
four he did well yeah he did he was like
this quadrant how does it you know he's
like right to pain here here here and
here
and I let him know that at certain
points it's certain there was a quadrant
hotspot oh no need to get you've already
gotten pretty specific but I mean it was
like please let this be over quickly man
and then it was and I sit back up and I
talked to him and he he had on a glove
at that point I was like oh I didn't see
him put on a glove I guess he had on the
glove the whole time that would be
proper well yeah yeah but I didn't
remember him putting on a glove he's
always going bare head yeah I felt at
one point I felt like I needed to stop
and I'll ask him but he did and the
glove was coming off at that point but
then he's like talking talking talking
and I'm like just trying to recover from
the moment and the whole time I'm
thinking when this is over and we're
gonna shake his hand
mm-hmm so no yeah my hands were back I
was like I was like propped up I was
propped back on the on the the bench the
seat right the table thingy and then he
tells me everything is I want you to I
want you to try this shrinking
suppository so I'm I'm doing that for a
couple weeks and then come back and I'm
like okay and I'm not extending my hands
or anything and then he's like it's like
any questions I'm like nope look at the
hint and then he's like well let me
summarize and he summarizes everything
and then it's like I keep thinking is
gonna be over and then he's like here
comes the hand and then of course [ __ ] I
shook his hand I'm not gonna deny he
took the glove off though the glove was
the glove was off at this point
and I shook the hand but it did feel
weird I mean he didn't shake my hand
when he first met me and he had just I
mean while I was waiting I heard like
uncomfortable sounds from the room next
door like oh really yeah I could hear
through the wall he was in there with
another purse
and it was not going well at one point I
heard someone say are you gonna be able
to drive home oh gosh this is right
before he comes in you had a bad
experience right before he comes in when
are you gonna be able to drive home yeah
my guy there was nobody I was the first
one there the no one else was in the
waiting room there was nobody else
having a question whether or not they
were gonna drive home wow what was he
doing to that guy I don't want to know I
neither man I think we can move on now
what do we learn here though I mean
we're going we're gonna I think it's
gonna happen multiple times over the
next couple of months I mean they they
want us both back yeah I just think
there's gonna be more probing I think
that part of getting older and I went to
the dentist this morning
I mean I got it going in both orifices
but that's probably I mean the dentist
is normal thing it's like kind of a
normal thing six months but I'm seeing a
pattern here I'm just I'm getting
comfortable with just getting in a chair
or on a table and people are just
inserting stuff well profession what
professionals are professional yeah be
very specific as important I think
there's getting comfortable which I
think that's part of getting older is
understanding that yeah you're moving
into this stage you're moving into the
stage where you have to be evaluated by
professionals physically in order to
make sure that you make it through the
next half of your life man as we're have
our man that's what's happening I don't
know what the current life expectancy
for an American male is but I got to
assume we're like halfway there I mean
that's literally what is happening to us
right now
you don't think it's in the mid 80s what
is the life expectancy for a an adult
male American and I'm gonna guess that
the answer is four you think is 84 I
would say is 81 for a male and then for
a female I would say it's 85 for a
female I'm saying 84 and 86 and then
Rhett is saying 80 what 1 and 85
okay so it was 78 78 what did I say man
you said 81 no for a man I said anyone I
don't remember what you said link either
way you look at it we're more than
halfway there man urug I'm exactly
halfway there and here's the bomb
exactly halfway there and you're almost
halfway there
the problem is Oh people have just
started putting their finger in our
butts yeah and that's the we should it
all we've got to look for [ __ ] out
welcome use a better analogy we should
have been allowing that to happen much
earlier if there's a certain amount of
finger pokes that you but the finger
pokes don't have any impact or effect in
the first 40 years you know fact most
people don't need them but you know
another thing that has happened because
I think we should stop talking about the
condition let's move let's talk about
let's move away from it another thing
that has happened is since the last time
we hadn't we made an ear biscuit we both
have teenager children now yeah Lily
turned 13 a year ago and lock just
turned 13 thirteen now so we both have
13 year olds and I mean my son wasn't
even with me when he turned 13 he was in
Africa it's funny because Lily was in
China look at us we sent him awaited to
become Tina yeah like go to the other
side of the earth if you're gonna become
a teenager she had don't be with me Lily
had a friend who's her best one of her
best friends dad was working for Disney
building the park over there yeah
building the Shanghai Disney right I
said they lived over there for I can't
remember how many months four months six
months maybe I think they were over
there almost a year that's right
remember maybe but Lily went over for a
couple weeks
she went over for a couple of weeks with
friends of the with family members so
she flew over there with them and she
turned 13 and we didn't you know we
didn't didn't even send her a card it
turned out she you know she made it it
turned out we didn't need to be there
for her to become a teenager right it
still happens whether you're there or
not it's not like quantum mechanics and
in Lock turned 13 in Africa because he
went there with my wife one of his when
his friends again it's a friend
connection one of his friends has
started a charity over there helping to
build schools and giving giving kids
resources and access to health services
and that kind of thing and he went over
there with some of his friends and he
was in a hut I mean so they did a lot of
things they were in Uganda but there was
one night the day of his birthday where
they went to like a remote village so I
mean he stayed they stayed in like a
relatively nice hotel and they stayed in
some different places but there was the
time that they went to the remote
village in name it was like we're going
to let you guys see what it's like to
stay in a hut literally a hut like is
somebody's house it's not like like
floor types it just bring the Western
tourists in and had them stay in a
museum piece no it's like this is
someone's home that you stay in so Jesse
and Locke stayed in this person's home
and inside of a mosquito net you know
you had to have a mosquito net yeah no
they had all their like malaria stuff
before they went had to be in the
mosquito net and they he turned 13 in a
mosquito net and go in this mosquito net
and what did he say about it I mean it
was it they sleep in the mosquito net or
was it just for them and I know yeah
they all sleeping if you have access to
a mosquito net you use it and that's in
fact that's one of the easiest ways to
help people in Africa is with mosquito
nets it actually is the most effective
way that you can give that you can
donate in terms of how your dollar
related impacts saving a human life is
through a mosquito net anyway so they
had a birthday party for him in this
little village
and they made a cake for him and they
thought his name was Rocky
how did because his name is Locke and
they like brought him up front and they
were like rocky and he was like yeah he
liked it in front of rookies they sing
happy birthday to Rocky so not only did
you become 13 now he's we call him Rocky
he got a new name yeah he got a whole
new name I came back from Africa with a
new name a new identity rocky he's gonna
be a boxer and but you know I wrote this
I wrote it on his card and you know I I
try to I always write a reg I rather
write less well and I try to write a
rather lengthy meaty somewhat
substantial thing in there and there
birthday cards yeah yeah you know my
wife got me into that because that's
kind of her family always my family on
the other hand was always like the way
that you know the way that my mom is
always written in birthday cards has
been like she'll take what the card says
inside and show like underline three
words yes yes surely take what was
written inside the card which is the
perfect thing that she selected and
bought and then she'll at her own
emphasis emphasis added by Diane and
then should be like what he said and
then she's and of course she says above
here and and she will write you know a
couple of sentences and that's how I
always was I was like listen take people
these people know that I love them and I
can communicate that in other ways than
sitting down to writing a card but then
when I met Jesse it was like oh no her
family does things different so they
would write very long you know you in
fact you had to write a well-thought-out
long different thing it couldn't be the
same thing that you said last year cuz
they keep it right and now compare and
so now you know I'm writing things for
Valentine's Day and for birthday from
from a wife and of course I'm writing
some thoughtful but I think this is it's
a better tradition I think this is a
good adaptation that our family is made
this is a good thing that you're being
forced to do because I think that the
kids will look back and think like okay
this is what this is where I was in my
life and this is what my dad was
communicating to me and also hopefully
something that I say now
we'll have some sort of impact but you
just start thinking I'm just like man
he's 13 he is he is who he's going to be
like that's what I'm just like I could I
mean I I mean I should I should write
something thoughtful and I'm not saying
I'm not saying I'm no longer parenting
but you just started thinking it's just
like in a lot of ways it's over with our
with our teenagers we can guide and we
can help direct and we can be there and
we can answer questions and we can help
them make good decisions and we're gonna
continue to do all those things but when
it comes to like the core of who they
are as a person the kind of person that
they're gonna be it is largely
determined it has largely been
determined well that it's not gonna keep
us from continuing to try oh you keep
trying but you wrote I mean see is that
what you wrote it you wrote something in
there I said you are who you are know
you did hasta LaVista
no no I know I go on and he opened it in
the in the mosquito net I well I don't
know I haven't talked to him about the
opening of the card what I'm trying to
say is that I wanted it to be impactful
and I wanted it to be substantial and I
wanted it to be like mmm this is from a
dad and I'm turning 13 this is a big
deal and I said I said all those things
and I think it was meaningful I haven't
talked to him about it but I'm sure it
was meaningful as it brought it up but
what I would but what I was thinking as
I was writing it is like man 13 years
have passed it's like if this was a
hundred years ago I'll be like son good
luck with your farm you know what I mean
yeah I send him all it I'll be like he'd
have a woman and they'd be going off and
they'd have a family you know I was like
a knit like a year from now and you'd be
dying yeah and I would have died already
a life expectancy both what it was for
Lily
we gave her a journal and then I wrote
so she does the writing Wow he has I
write me something no I wrote a big
thing at the front of the journal that
was basically a very similar thing like
hey this is my fatherly perspective on
where you are and
you know this is a big trip for you and
then it there was inspirational
assignments like I I want you to write
in this journal to remember the things
that are happening I want you to write
something every day you know I probably
got a little overbearing it was like
write something in a journal every day
and here's a list of questions that will
fill a half a page of me just writing
those out of questions that you can ask
yourself and reflect on like about the
culture and how things are different and
I just you know I wanted to empower her
to reflect and remember snow gave like
thought starters well it's not created
like a journal that you could have sold
to any child I was going to China a
workbook yeah that's a business idea you
know you find out where the kids going
and you give him a series of questions
and then when she came back she was like
look at all the pictures I took who she
didn't answer your questions well I mean
we still have this negative you know I
mean I think that I don't know if she
wrote in the journal every day I don't I
didn't feel like it was my business to
you have a police the journal it was
like hey this is you know maybe I'm
actually being a little overbearing and
giving specific assignments but you know
that's how I would interpret it but it's
okay right I know I have antennas to do
that so that's why I on the back end I'm
like I'm not gonna demand that I read
the journal I mean it is her journal she
it was her prerogative to write stuff in
it or or not and that's again that's the
best I can do I can still I can give
journals I can give cards at Valentines
Day that say how amazing she is and
things like that I I think the the best
we can do is once you know it's whatever
life throws at you and our kids that
they that they're able to respond and it
and life doesn't crush them but they but
they own it you know it's like I'm
grabbing life by the by the horns I want
to be a proctologist I'm gonna do it
well that's nothing I understand what
that what that means but that's what I
want to do with my life I've told her
that she brothers didn't do it but she's
into it I was trying to bring it back to
the party ology you're not biting that's
okay
but I can talk about this we you know
you know I'll tell you guys I took
speaking of Lily we took her in for just
an annual checkup and the doctor
diagnosed well the doctor said you know
they always check for scoliosis I think
it's just something you do every year
they did it for us in school without she
they had concerns sent her to a
specialist and then to make a very long
story short she was diagnosed with
severe scoliosis yeah you know we we get
the x-ray the specialist looks at it and
we look at this thing and her back is
like an S I mean it's it just it floored
us and you know we when we were driving
to the specialist we knew that she had
she had curves we had you know we had
done research about well given certain
measurements does that mean that there's
gonna be bracing that she has to wear a
brace as she goes through puberty as she
goes through a growth growth spurt to
not correct it but just as to stop the
curve from getting worse so the after
she's through a ghost growth spurt is
something that many people are just live
with and having a normal life even
though there's their spine is curved or
does this mean that does mean something
more does this mean surgery or some
other course of action that the internet
and the first doctor hadn't told us yet
so on the way to the specialist I'm
riding lillies riding with me and then
Kristi's driving separately so that I
can leave and come to I have to come
into work we had to shoot something yeah
that day and so I was gonna take her
have some time with her and then she was
gonna ride back with Kristi and I just
remember telling her on the way there
based on the measurements of your curves
and the research that I've done on the
Internet yeah which is all the
information I can find so far I just
feel like
you know whatever it is we're gonna
we're gonna figure this out we're gonna
get through this but you know it I'm I'm
confident that it's not gonna be surgery
the doctors not gonna tell us surgery
like I actually told her that I just
felt I felt confident based on how the
curves were measured right but then when
we get in with the specialist his
measurements were a more accurate you
know that's why you go to a specialist
for the specialization but and they were
worse and you know I I think in
retrospect he's dealt with this so much
he knew that it takes a while to sink in
he gave us all the information and it
was in the in a masterful way but it
just is it's almost impossible for it
all to sink in but basically the first
thing he told us was these are where her
curves are this is what this means this
is this these are the these are the
facts this is what research has taught
us this is what experience has taught us
therefore we're recommending spinal
fusion surgery for Lily of course it's
me Christy and Lily in the room and he
thinks he's explaining a lot of it and I
just didn't think he was gonna say that
you know so it like it it absolutely
floored me like Christy and I were just
speechless and the doctor according he
was very understanding anything he
allowed us to ask questions but there
was that moment where I was like I don't
know what to say we're gonna have to
regroup on this but then like you catch
your breath and you ask question and we
asked some clarifying questions about
what that meant what the what all the
alternatives were going to clarify
because it's such a major surgery
I mean you because a lot of people will
be like don't don't get surgery all
right so I mean right you've gotten a
second opinion you you gotta talk to
multiple people we've gotten it we've
gotten a I mean since then yeah we've
gotten we've got a second opinion in a
third opinion and we've explored many
other options
many different types of procedures and
come to the conclusion that yes this is
the right decision for for Lily but it's
not the decision and so surgery is
scheduled for not too far down the road
but and it's like you know it's pretty
much the whole middle of her back you
know it's like it's major its major but
in that moment when we're sitting there
I look at Lily and like we're floored
and I mean she was surprised but I was I
was just I was surprised that her
reaction was well I know what I want to
do but I want to hear what you guys
think it's like that's what she said so
then we were like well this is not an
easy decision it's probably not we're
not gonna make it right here in the in
the doctor's office we're gonna have to
think about this and look at all look at
all of our options right and she was
like you know if this is what needs to
happen I'm ready to do it you know if
the surgery's the right thing I want to
do it and you know it wasn't her first
reaction wasn't fear it was okay if this
is how we have to move forward and let's
do it and you know I was reflected on
that a lot and I was you know what we
left I mean we left the doctor's office
we went out we got in the van and it was
like the three of us and like we talked
about it some more and we cried you know
all three of us cried because it it was
it's of course it was and it is very
scary but the fact that you know you
know as a 13 year old to be struck was
with such you know scary news that she
wasn't dominated by fear if she wasn't
debilitated by it she was able to you
know have I don't know if the I don't
want to say it was a mature response for
her it was her honest response was okay
let's let's engage let's let's figure
this out she handled it better than she
handled it better than I did
yes she did yeah then I did certainly
and
you know we've had more conversations
there's been more tears there's been a
lot of I mean a lot of just being honest
and saying oh it's staying on the same
page and trying to figure it out but I
mean it's my point is in my you know
it's times like that that you figure out
who your kid is as a person
it's and you start to look at your kid
not as a kid anymore but as another
human you know it's like it could be you
know it could be you it could be me it
could be you know well it stuffs gonna
hit all of us and what you realize is
that you you know we'd like to take a
lot of credit for things you right right
but the fact is is that her response to
that situation is not something that you
taught her or your wife saw her because
I know you and your wife yeah know that
if you were personally impacted by that
you would if I was personally impacted
by that like I'm we've already
established I'm a hypochondriac
i it's in my genes to just worry about
that like if I was facing that you know
I've told the story before when I found
out that I had herniated discs which can
in some cases it's some extreme cases
result in a spinal fusion surgery of
just a couple of vertebrae yeah I
fainted when the doctor told me that I
had right herniated discs in the room by
yourself and when he told me and I left
the room and then I fainted because I
was freaking out it came to before he
came back in and then you acted like
nothing had yet yeah but so I but I
think we should take some comfort in
that yeah all of us as individuals and
as parents because the fact is is that
you do what you can this is not where
this is not advocating for not parenting
this is this is advocating definitely
for parenting and supporting and being
there but it's also kind of taking the
pressure off yourself because you could
not have done anything to prepare Lily
for that situation because you
personally as a mature adult were not
prepared for it but it was in her
disposition to be prepared for that
moment I mean and it it's certainly it's
not like it's easy for I'm not saying a
little bit it's it's
both factors I mean you do you do
everything you can to raise your kid and
and demin I mean we you go it's not the
first hard time we've been through and
you figure that out as a family
everything you go through and you learn
from all that stuff I mean you we are we
are having an impact on who our kids are
well yes but but I'm saying but that's
that side of it is the side that you
always hear right that's the side that
you hear in all the parenting books I
mean parenting books the whole parenting
book market is completely based on the
presumption that you can have a drastic
impact on the lives of your children and
you can but that's that that sells books
and it gives people jobs and nobody
wants to hear well your kid is also from
for a lot of other reasons both nature
and nurture and things that are outside
of your control going to be a certain
way
no that's nobody wants to hear that
because it means it makes you feel
powerless and it makes you feel like you
don't have a lot of control but it
doesn't mean that it's not largely true
in fact I was listening to a podcast I
can't remember which one it was but like
one of the foremost child psychologists
was the guest on the show and he was
basically singing exactly what I'm
saying right now I'm not I'm no expert
he is actually an expert and he's like
there's a lot of people out there who
claim to know a whole lot about
psychology of children and what we have
found through there's no every study has
been very inconclusive and actually what
our research tells us when you look at
all the research is that in a large
measure kids are gonna be who they're
going to be doesn't mean that parenting
is not very important and then you put
kids in one situation on one side of the
earth and another kid in another
situation that their circumstances are
definitely going to determine many
things about their future and their
outcome but personality makeup and
disposition is a big part of that is
going to be determined by genetics and
and then there'll be some
very formative events that can kind of
send things in different ways but as a
parent I mean first of all I think
there's a balance here because our wives
have been the ones who've read all the
parenting books and have like obsessed
about you know they've homeschool the
kids yeah take their credit David David
they've invested all this time into and
I think there's been a measurable impact
so I don't want to diminish that at the
same time like we can take comfort in
the fact that it's like okay we do what
we can but in the in the in the midst of
a real trying moment like this like her
finding out that she's got to have the
surgery it's like that that response
that she's gonna have us kind of largely
determine about who she just is mm-hmm
and I want to make sure that in sharing
the story that and I'm just concerned
that I don't want to make sure I'm not
leaving a lot of unanswered questions
that people would be concerned about
yeah right
having not like calculated exactly how I
wanted to talk about it or anything as
in terms of like when is this thing
we're talking like early May
so there's I mean it's it's I guess I
owe you an update after that point but
yeah we feel very I don't know is there
any audience you know I mean I think you
covered it she's you know the surgery is
definitely the best option given her
circumstances and it's gonna be a
serious spinal fusion surgery with a
pretty long recovery time but the
there's lots of people who've had the
surgery lots of you can go there's lots
of people on YouTube that was interested
you know you've made YouTube videos
about their journey yeah I think surgery
I came back we were in the van we we
were when I said that like we were
crying together and then we I I still
had to come in you know it's like I was
I think because of some sort of
circumstance with like us going to
Sundance which then I wasn't going to
Oh to Sundance and then lily and Christy
both told me to keep our plans to go to
Sundance even though it was it I didn't
want to go and I didn't want to leave
them at that point they wanted me to go
and that turned out to be a good
situation for all of us for that to
happen we had to come in and shoot good
mythical so we had to come in and we had
to shoot good mythical morning before we
left for that but that so then I'm
driving in alone and I'm just thinking I
can't I you know I knew that we had a
shoot and I was like I can't talk about
this because then we wouldn't be able to
shoot the episode Cameron what the
episode was at this point and then it's
like in the drive-in and just that was
kind of the conclusion it's like I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna talk about this
because I'm gonna get upset we're gonna
be able to shoot we could talk about
which is interesting I think a lot of
people you know we're not vloggers right
I mean we where we do unscripted video
when we do good mythical morning and it
guess it can technically be classified
as a vlog right but we're not like
family vloggers who are like hey we're
letting you into our family and yeah and
give me this instead we make a show we
make a show that has a very specific
purpose and the primary purpose of good
mythical morning is to entertain the
audience and to give people a break from
the boat the bullcrap yeah because that
day everybody's got stuff everyone's
learning
yeah same type of information that Lily
learned that morning and you know
watching our show is a reprieve you know
I'm what people when they get you know
that bad news that way they can count on
our show to be a reprieve in those you
know 15 minutes and people may say
listen no but if you guys are going
through something super serious like
that just stop and tell us or make the
show about that it's like no we're not
gonna do that we're gonna we're talking
about it on your biscuits yeah you know
I mean that's another reason to do ear
biscuits we're gonna talk about things
like this that we're not gonna bring
into good mythical morning because
that's not the purpose of that
show it's not it's not designed to be
this open book into our lives it's
designed to be it's a particular type of
entertainment but ironically I was
trying to remember where I was going
with that but okay so when I came in I
had enough breathing time on my drive in
that when I didn't make an active
decision but I I walked into our office
before we had a shoot and you were like
tell me about it and then I'm not gonna
be I can't talk about it right now I
just told you about it and it was like
it actually made me feel better to just
be able to talk through it because it's
like okay I'm such a verbal processor
that I can if I stay inside of my own
head it would just be like a fear cycle
of this is horrible so it was it was
helpful for me to field your questions
and then it's like you know you started
looking on the internet immediately but
we pulled up YouTube videos that the
irony is we talked we said we didn't
talk about this stuff on YouTube but
then we ended up finding a lot of people
mostly girls I mean so many girls well
it's actually much more common in
females yeah who are like beginning to
go through puberty at that age or
whatever who the type of scoliosis it's
caught can remember the name right now
but basically the name says they don't
know why where what causes it that's in
the name of it but a lot of these girls
have put their my scoliosis story and a
lot of a lot of them had had the spinal
fusion surgery and it kind of vlog
through the process or put their
before-and-after pictures and just kind
of talked about the process I think when
you go through it it's a type of thing
and we've met other kids who were are
going through and have gone through the
surgery and in person and Lily has
talked to him become friends with some
of them but uh but the first exposure
was YouTube videos that you and I
watched that then I shared with Christy
and Lily and that it it gave us a lot of
comfort and confidence that we there is
a there was a path yeah you know we we
didn't know if it was our path yet but
we
know that it was a valuable path that
these people went on YouTube shared
their stories and we immediately
benefited from it I think that was my
point
yeah it all comes back to YouTube it's
all about you - yeah that's really a
mana tiger they monetize their surgery
we're monetizing this without YouTube we
wouldn't be here link would had wouldn't
have no hope not true but to bring it
back to again we didn't know what the
show was gonna be about this is what it
has become which man we took a turn here
we open we spread the cheeks spread the
cheek for the proctologist for for a
good half hour and then we open our
hearts man I mean this is this is an ear
biscuit this is what makes a complete
air biscuit it's not always gonna be
this but to round out the whole point of
the show I guess which became about us
getting older I think there's a few
markers right there's a few markers one
is the being probed personally but then
there's this thing that I think I've
experienced I know you've experienced
ever since I saw I held my first child
lock in my hands I mean
rocki rocki time I rock yeah I was like
oh crap oh no I'm gonna worry a lot
about this mm-hmm
you know what I'm saying like yeah now
I'll have to I have to worry about this
child because I'm so concerned about
them and this is going to be difficult
for me
you know this I'm not like you kind of
like feel your heart like kind of change
a little bit you grow a little bit and
become a little bit more vulnerable and
I plan your the grant I don't want to be
one of those guys it's like you don't
understand life if you don't have
children you know you have a lot more
free time and can see a lot more movies
if you don't have children so that's
pretty much what it boils down there are
a lot of reasons not to have children
but movies movies free free time just
that's what you mean oh the good life
okay
but the when you do have a kid it it
brings this sense of responsibility and
this
constant worrying about their welfare
you know so would what something like
Lily's going through is just these kinds
of things are gonna happen these are the
kind of things that you dread but are
the kind of things that you happen and
it's out of your control even though the
firt our first thing was how did we not
notice this and is it our fault that it
got to this point right and you know
that that's not the case but that's
still the first thing you think cuz you
want to think that you can have control
over something especially if you really
love it yeah you were trying to
summarize well you know that is that's
where we're that's where we're at right
now we're in a place where we're going
to the doctor for ourselves and for our
children that that's that's where we're
at and we're gonna keep doing your
biscuits we're gonna we're gonna bring
you a biscuit every week and to give you
a little preview of what season three
might hold okay it's gonna be a lot I
would say it's gonna be a lot looser and
a lot different and may go a lot more
places in different places than previous
seasons have gone yeah because we
haven't planted
I mean I'm well I would say you haven't
even dis we've discussed we haven't
discussed what it will be we've
discussed what we don't want it to be
the same philosophy that I've been
taking with my hair in 2017 yeah just
letting it do what it wants to do is the
same philosophy that we're taking with
your biscuits we're gonna let it be what
it wants to be sometimes it's going to
be the two of us sometimes we're gonna
bring somebody else it's not you know
the previous two seasons the majority of
the episodes were us just sitting down
and doing like a very deep interview
with most often a youtube personality
right not saying that's not going to
happen but that's not going to be the
main thrust of the show we're going to
talk to each other a lot we're gonna
talk to other people we may be talking
to you guys at some point taking your
questions what we don't know we're gonna
keep it open we're going to keep it
loose but keep it tight and put the one
thing we're gonna do is we're gonna
Peter we're gonna keep doing it not like
I think
yeah keep it loose and keep it tidy
that's what we almost called this this
podcast sphincter but but we didn't yeah
and we don't thankfully we didn't but
that might be the name of the first
episode but if we take this podcast to
Uganda intent it may see it may be
called sphincter yeah it may get a new
name who knows I don't know how it
translates to Ugandan thank you guys
leave a review on iTunes SoundCloud or
you don't leave YouTube reviews you
gonna leave a comment or a like if
you're watching this on YouTube also
subscribe to that this is mythical
channel for more ear biscuits and other
content throughout the week thank you
for being your mythical best yes
[Music]